[Music]  in the frozen landscape of the canadian  arctic this arctic fox welcomed human  visitors  clearly curious the fox even approached  the expedition leader before walking  away  the arctic fox is so well adapted to the  frigid weather that it can survive  temperatures as low as -58 degrees  fahrenheit  the fox sports small ears a short muzzle  furry souls and lives in burrows  protecting it from blizzards  [Music]  the fox's white coat acts as camouflage  and even changes color as the seasons  change  [Music]  during the coldest of months the fox  will often rely on polar bears to do the  hunting picking up scraps  currently arctic fox populations are  stable and of least concern to the iucn  red list  [Music]  do  you